here is Sam Harris on Lex Friedman's
podcast still
illogically trying to explain his
position on vax's and it just doesn't
make any sense go against skepticism of
the safety and efficacy of the vaccine
so people who get nervous about
the vaccine but don't fall into the
usual anti-vaxx Camp which I think there
was a significant enough number they're
asking they're getting nervous I mean
the sense was that you weren't open
enough to the skepticism I understand
that people have that sense I'll tell
you how I thought about it and think
about it one again it was a moving
Target so there was a point in the
timeline where
it was totally rational to expect that
the vaccines
were were both working but both they
were
they were reasonably safe and that and
that covid was reasonably dangerous and
that the trade-off for basically
everyone was it was rational to get
vaccinated given how many given the
level of testing it was just obviously
reasonable to get vaccinated
in especially because there was every
reason to expect that while it wasn't a
perfectly sterilizing vaccine it was
going to knock down transmission a lot
and that matters and so it wasn't just a
personal choice you were actually being
a good citizen when you decided to run
whatever risk you you were going to run
to get vaccinated man there's so much
there uh first off to say it was
completely rational to think that there
was a point on the timeline that it was
completely rational to think they were
safe I mean it was completely rational
to think they weren't safe they were
being pushed on everybody for a virus
that had over
99.9 chance of recovery from if you were
relatively healthy if you were very
elderly or had several other
comorbidities much like you wouldn't
want to get the flu you also didn't want
to get coveted but the idea that it was
rational to think they were safe like
what happened to skepticism I thought
Skeptics I mean Sam and the atheist
community and that sort of section of
the secular left I thought their entire
thing was about skepticism you don't
just accept answers we're not like those
stupid religious people who just accept
that floating Sky God that would be
their General position we think about
things we question things
why did I end up questioning the vaccine
why did I not get vaccinated and clearly
that has turned out to be the correct
position and millions and millions of
other people took that same position and
now are quite happy about it there are
tons not only of people who are vaccine
injured we'll get to that in a second
but there are tons of people who now are
vaxxed who were forced to get backs who
did not want to get backs but they were
forced because of their job or having to
travel internationally whatever their
choice was that you know you eventually
got pushed into a corner and you made
your choice but there are tons of people
who are now trying to figure out ways to
detox from The Backs we know that people
who get booster after booster after
booster still are getting covered I had
Robert Malone on the show The basically
the inventor of the MRNA vaccines saying
that he at this point thinks it's going
to get way way worse that the vaccines
are actually degrading your immune
system so there was no point in the
timeline where it was totally rational
to just believe the machine but that
would be my position generally when it
comes to people like Sam it's like you
can say you're an atheist but you end up
believing in something one way or
another
foreign
[Music]